nachdem
meine erste reaction auf too hot to
handle Germany ja für den ein oder
anderen Eklat und Skandal bei der ein
oder anderen Teilnehmerin dort gesorgt
hat habe ich doch einfach mal weiter
darauf die Teilnehmer glauben wirklich
dass sie bei tropical Desire sind und
ich habe gerade eine Bestellung
aufgegeben die mir hilft mein Retreat
Programm zu starten ich finde es halt
crazy das niemand von denen irgendwie so
Loki mal dachte Mensch von den Kamera
Leuten sieht schon sehr professionell
aus für so eine deutsche tropical Desire
Show und das da vielleicht auch irgendwo
in meinem Netflix an irgendeiner Stelle
stand sowas ja nicht schneller ist halt
auch auf jeden Fall eine Bombe wird mich
sehr sehr verrückt machen also einfach
durch ihre Art und ihr Äußeres stella
ist mein Favorite also da werden wir uns
definitiv mal auf die Füße treten ne ich
glaube da gibt's mehrere Leute was ich
so crazy finde ist es dir halt wirklich
alle seit gefühlt halt in dieser Serie 3
Minuten auf dieser Insel sind und jetzt
so direkt alle sagen können
[Musik]
mit Namen sorry
schreiben würde dann wäre es glaube ich
der Tobias
ich im Ausland an aber ich hätte gern
Tobias
fragt man sich ob er auch was anderes
kommt
die Serie eigentlich auch zu cold to
Handeln nennen meine Ansicht nach bisher
aber Jungs Konversation ist extrem
wichtig untereinander okay das ist
wirklich klären keine Aktion hinter dem
Rücken oder so
auf jeden Fall
die Sache ist bei Jungs gibt sowas
wirklich
also ich kann das so sagen ich hatte
eigentlich glaube ich noch nie Stress
mit dem Typen wegen dem Girl was ich
beim Mädels bisher so mitbekommen habe
boah aber egal welches Strategie ihr
habt in fünf Stunden ist Ende
oh 5 Stunden noch
bis dahin müssen wir auf jeden Fall
heute gucken ich will auf jeden Fall
noch die Reaktion mitnehmen wie die das
erfahren dass sie gar nichts miteinander
haben
Ihre Bestellung was ist das und wie
funktioniert es
das ist ein zometal seine Aufgabe ist es
heute Abend den Erregungsgrad meiner
Teilnehmer zu messen ja da waren vorhin
schon passiv konnte ich alle nicht
reinschneiden haben die gerade den
Betten Raum hier entdeckt und alle
Teilnehmer labern irgendwas plus 18
mäßiges
ey wenn da ich finde es boah nee ich
würde so ich kriege Gänsehaut wenn ich
das alles so sehen
die Frage ist was zur Hölle raus
auf einmal steht da dieses Riesenteil
hier auch
keine Sorge Leute Aufklärung Naht unsere
Pariserin erklärt den Teilnehmern gerade
dass es ein oh mein Gott
gesehen habe auf den T-Shirts hier ist
steht wirklich tropical Desire drauf
also Netflix hat sich wirklich Mühe
gegeben
[Musik]
es gibt Männer die nicht ganz genau
wissen wie man mit der Zunge umgeht aber
ich glaube da kann ich noch auf viel
gespannt sein was Tobi angeht ich habe
eine ganz kurze Frage zu diesem
generellen Interviews ne wie gesagt ich
schaue keinen Assi TV ich schaue kein
reality TV gar nichts machen die diese
Interviews einmal am Tag Abend so wie
ich mir das produktionstechnisch am
sinnvollsten vorstellen kann oder
direkt nach solchen Situationen weil so
wie sie sich ja hier gerade freut in
dieser Szene muss man eigentlich denken
Netflix oder tropical Designer die haben
das über die Live Kameras beobachtet
haben gesehen aha der Tobias und
Birgit die knutschen gerade in der
Dusche rum zack komm mal her ab ins
Interview so was sagt ihr zum Kuss wie
geht's euch was denkt ihr für die
Zukunft etwas erhofft ihr euch von der
von
Klima also wann machen die sowas
weil mit solchen Emotionen das muss er
entweder komplett gefaked sein oder am
nach der Nacht gekommen
warte mal oh mein Gott
auch wieder vielleicht aus
produktionstechnischer Sicht eine ganz
ganz dumme Frage aber das muss doch
alles gefaked sein ich meine Spur wir
mal einen kleinen Moment zurück hier
liegt Emily mit Acker attacker keine
Ahnung was auf der Liege und dann laufen
hier Kevin mit der anderen her genau vor
denen während die genau da so liegen
setzen sich hin und jetzt geht's
wahrscheinlich darum dass Kevin genau
mit der jetzt plötzlich quatschen
verkabelt ist mit perfekten Kamera
Perspektiven
das heißt es muss doch alles gesettet
sein als wenn die sich da gedacht haben
oh die beiden liegen da Kevin schnappt
sich mir komm wir gehen kurz vor denen
her perfekt und dann setzen uns hier hin
damit wir dann hier unser Interview
machen können und unsere perfekt also
das ist doch irgendwie
ich weiß also so funktioniert der ganze
Lachs natürlich auch so baut man eine
Story auf und es wäre natürlich auch
langweilig wenn jetzt direkt gehen
würden bumsen keine Ahnung was so klar
safe aber
das dann Leute dann also das ist doch
kann man sowas schauen
am Anfang ich glaube ein bisschen
zurückhaltend danach aber ich kann auch
anders und aus mir rauskommen
bin ich plötzlich Grieche also ich
komme ich lass es alles es ist so komm
ich kann mich da Netflix ich bin dabei
[Musik]
das heißt doch Netflix hat sich direkt
gedacht komm wir bauen eine Story auf
ich kann es euch jetzt schon sagen ich
schwöre bei Gott ich habe noch nicht
weiter geguckt als diese stelle ich rege
hier zusammen mit euch drauf so die
Netflix also es wird safe safe safe safe
ablaufen dass diese Emily und zwar mit
diesem Alter hat keine Ahnung
Aktenkoffer damit irgendwie was hat und
dann sind die irgendwann auseinander und
Emily geht dann zu Kevin und er ist
irgendwie sauer auf 100% zu laufen das
wird der rote Faden sein keine Comedy
ähm
mich ein bisschen motiviert haben
motiviert nein
ich räume weg also Stella Check Tobi
aber auch Anna Fabio und Dennis haben
ein Auge auf Stella geworfen während
Laura Kevin datet auf den Emily steht
auf die Acker steht
schneller keine Chance
[Musik]
die sind also gerade auf irgend so einer
goldenen Party
und derjenige der als erstes zu jemand
hin Sprint hat was mit der Person und
Emily ist jetzt ihre Mitbewerberin
vorausgesprungen das heißt sowohl ist
das Mädel also siehe jetzt aber auf
Emily als auch ATA Kata Aktienbörse
ich kann das nicht mehr
ich kann ich kann es nicht mehr wie viel
Zeit haben wir noch bis zum Verbot aber
die Zeit rennt drei Stunden noch
machen wir nicht mehr heute ich habe es
mir gewünscht aber ich kann nicht mehr
die Folge geht auch noch irgendwie eine
Viertelstunde oder so wenn ihr wollt
dass ich auch noch auf diesen Moment
reagiere wo die dann erfahren dass sie
nichts miteinander haben dürfen dann
lasst einen Daumen hoch und ein Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke damit ihr meine
nächste reaction auf 2 cold to head ach
komm mach's gut